[Musik]
hey leute was geglaubt und jetzt
willkommen
ein video der leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut ich bin hier gerade in
österreich auf jeden fall sind wir hier
im skiurlaub
genau heute nacht als richtig krass
neuschnee gegeben beziehungsweise eben
als auch noch geschneit wenn man sich
das hier mal anschaut da sind schon die
ganzen skifahrer und darum ist die piste
die genau bei uns um die ecke ist vom
hotel das wetter wird so langsam besser
aber wir haben jetzt gleich 10 uhr und
heute ist auch schon der dritte spieltag
ich habe mir gedacht komm heute machst
du mal so im kleinen block den mit japan
auf die gopro dabei und als kleine
talent ich habe euch jetzt mal gefragt
ja auch was für videos habt ihr bock war
dieser typ da draußen will ihr mich
verarschen
er guckt mich die ganze zeit an wie so
ein auto fand eigentlich hatte ich
geplant noch ein paar davon zu machen
instagram bestimmt 24 stunden wie ich
aussehe aber hier ein ganz viele
geschrieben wie bestimmt einen tag was
du machen sollst das heißt kleine
challenge heute allerdings allerdings
nur fünfmal also ich werde sich den
ganzen tag nach ihr richten das ist ja
dann auch zu themen und ich würde sagen
wir fahren jetzt los freust du dich
schon ganz so tief war also sehen uns
bis gleich
[Musik]
so leute ich bin jetzt hier gerade ganz
alleine künftig sehr wahrscheinlich
total komisch aus ich weiß ihr könnt
aber in die kommentare schreiben ob ihr
auch skifahren ist auf jeden fall
ziemlich gutes wetter heute nacht hat es
geschneit und jetzt scheint die sonne
[Musik]
und marie ist ja auch dabei und wie
gesagt ich habe mich heute die challenge
überlegt für den block damit was nicht
ganz so langweilig haben und ihr nur
aufnahmen seht wir machen heute
sie entscheidet alles genau so wie es
auch beim instagram video war also zum
beispiel gehen wir jetzt essen oder
gehen wir da ist dann muss ich dann
fahren wir da lang fahren
ich bin gespannt und was ist jetzt da
oben los auf jetzt wird es neblig schaut
mal ganz komisches wetter heute aber es
macht eine menge spaß wenn man darüber
schaut mega cool
[Musik]
so erste entscheidung entweder ich war
hier die buckelpiste runter die ist
ziemlich schwer oder ganz normal willst
du dass ich mich auf's maul läge ja echt
solche runter bahn
das ist eine verantwortung gerne wenn
das passiert dann fahren wir heute mal
hier runter fahren
hier war schon ganz schön angst hier
sieht ganz schön brutal aus
[Musik]
der zweite akt
so wir haben jetzt ein schnitzel und
spaghetti was durch nehmen müsse danke
ich echt eklig aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kollege als gut kannst du auf einem ski
fahren berlin
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt gerade hier im lift ist
ziemlich heiß und das schmeckt schon
wieder heute morgen lag hier auf dem tag
alles voll
und jetzt haben wir gar nichts mehr
drauf ich mache jetzt noch eine abfahrt
und dann geht es wieder mal ins hotel
weil der schnee wird so griffig wenig
griffig das gegenteil davon der schwede
patrik und macht nicht mehr so viel spaß
und da bin ich eben runter gefahren ganz
herstellen und schreibt mal ob er das
intro haben mich wenn ich ein guter
skifahrer
[Musik]
heute herzlich willkommen zurück alt ich
bin jetzt mal wieder oder was heißt mal
wieder ich bin jetzt zumindest wieder im
hotel bedeuten ein bisschen herunter
gefahren normalerweise gehen die lüftung
bis 16.30 mir ist aufgefallen ich hab
noch gar keine funkuhr gemacht deswegen
machen wir das mag ich würde sagen wir
fangen hier im bad an das bin ich hier
ist eine toilette und hier haben wir
sogar auch eine badewanne und das will
ich auch dass ich mein spiel da kann ich
mich immer schön schminken dann ist hier
irgendwie noch ein spiegel da ist das
bett hier haben wir einen fernseher
hier haben wir noch ein spiegel auch den
hab ich grad schon gezeigt hier auf dem
schrank habe ich meinen ganzen kamera
sachen ich habe auch noch eine drohne
mit die kann fliegen das wollte ich auch
noch mal testen die gopro und wenn man
hier auf dem balkon geht habe ich euch
ja eben schon gezeigt haben wir hier
sofort ein tool kann man rein ich bin
aus dem ersten stock es gibt aber auch
eine sauna hier und ich bin von beiden
echt begeistert und war wieder fürs
entscheiden soll ich an den polen an die
sauna
ich weiß nicht diese ist dann auch recht
entspannt das problem ist nur dass sind
immer so anpassen diesen akt das ist gut
das ist immer hart tor
da muss man immer so machen also weiter
ich teste jetzt mal mein iphone ob das
wasser durch ist und wir sehen uns
gleich im pool wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und da
so leute ich mache jetzt mal den
ultimativen iphone 7 unter wasser test
ich hatte das noch nie unter wasser und
ich bin gespannt ob das jetzt hält sieht
übrigens ganz cool aus hier okay weil
die einst verteidigung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es geht ja funktioniert so weiter
herzlich willkommen zurück pool station
ist vorbei ich war echt eineinhalb
stunden fast im pool
wir müssen jetzt die meisten runter und
wir haben uns jetzt was spezielles
überlegen und zwar kann ich ja nicht im
jogging hose runter gehen das ist ganz
klar dass davon hier nicht das ist ein
sehr vornehmlich könnte ich noch in die
hose gehen aber wir haben das jetzt so
abgemacht marie darf mein outfit
zusammenstellen wie sich heute abend aus
das darf sie jetzt gleich entscheiden
mache ich meine haare mache ich sie
nicht und so weiter und ich würde sagen
in der zeit in der sie das macht zeige
ich euch mal kurz den nacht hang es ist
nämlich schon 58 und das ist dunkel
aber da waren immer noch leute ski mega
cool oder
also leute bis gleich also ich meine
haare noch mal neue hoch machen oder so
lassen
eine kappe ich hab ich mit der kette zum
essen gehen auf dem weg muss ich die
anders und ich soll den 1
ich sollte ein restaurant mit diesen
schuhen gehen okay das finde ich noch
als ich plane ja keine mondlandung die
hose ist okay adidas shirt und adidas
cap und dieser pulli also ich würde
sagen
den kann ich aber weg legen weil sonst
ist das viel zu heiß naja gut dass
gleich so heute also sieht auf jeden
fall recht sportlich aus ich habe auf
jeden fall mega hunger heute gibt es für
die stäbchen gläubig oder hallo für
stückchen heute und wir sehen uns später
wieder rein
so leute welcome back also wenn man
schon am nächsten tag das wetter heute
ist extrem kacke wie man sehen kann in
diesen wolken heute was auch total neben
sich auf der piste ich kann ich
vielleicht mal
das ist nett von mir einbilden so wie
man sehen kann man sieht nichts ganz
toll
erstmalig dann aber irgendwie viel zu
müde und noch etwas aufzunehmen
wir hatten dann ziemlich schnell auch
keine ahnung 23 uhr sa so und ich habe
das video jetzt schon geschnitten
ich bin auch recht zufrieden mit dem
ganzen wieder ordentlich wollte jetzt
eigentlich nicht noch irgendwas zu
schädigen oder sohn wollte es einen klar
wir lassen hier schon sieben minuten
oder so an dieser stelle nochmal ganz
wichtig erstens ich habe noch eine neue
youtube kanal der link dazu dass ganze
nation schaut euch jeden fall mal vorbei
und lassen aber da ganz ganz wichtig
sonst würde ich sagen wir es noch mal um
da wir sehen uns morgen wieder
wahrscheinlich und wir hoffen mal
besseres wetter morgen das wäre echt
cool
ich bin gespannt ich hoffe es klappt ja
folgten wir uns irgendwas nicht ganz
wichtig den verdienst leben also leute
haut rein